hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we are in
round 4 of our coverage of the 2016 will
chess championship between magnus
carlsen and say howdy ya Ken so far
we've had three draws
Game three was pretty dramatic though
went 78 moves very long game Magnus
Carlsen had a winning line towards the
end did miss the continuation ended up
at drawing the game serving a caveat Ken
defended pretty well you know he just
was outplayed a little bit towards the
end game which most people are when they
play Magnus Carlsen but did defend well
enough
let's put Manas cross in some tough
spots and at the end of the day it was a
draw so coming into game for cardiac and
playing the white pieces kind of has a
little momentum going since he defended
so well he can actually take the lead if
he has a victory here so we'll go ahead
and get started started out with Pawnee
for Pawnee v met if 396 Bishop to b5 and
then pawn to a6 and this is kind of
exactly what we saw from game number two
which is odd because there was almost no
play from either side in Game two
Sergey karyakin didn't even try anything
creative in my opinion and it was a draw
shortly after move 30 mostly just
because they have to get to move 30 but
they probably could have even drawn
after 18 move so hoping that certainty
of karyakin is gonna be playing
something a little bit different because
not really sure what he was doing in
game two comes back to Bishop to a4
Knight f6 castle on the kingside so
first little change from what we've seen
in the past before he played just pawn
to d3 that's a small difference Eric
castle on the Kings side a Bishop d7
rook to e1 instead of defending with
pawn to a d3 pawn a b5 forcing the
bishop back here to b3 rook castle on
the Kings side and then pawn to h3 and
this is also a little bit different in
Game two we have pawn to h3 opening up
for the bishop to come back here to a -
so pawn to h3 a bishop here to b7 pawn
to d3 so we actually are starting to see
some of the moves who stalls from game 2
Pondy 6 and then pawn to a3 and this
sort of had me scratch
head I had flashbacks of game two which
was not that enjoyable so hoping that
these players have kind of studied this
with their teams and if something
different prepared than game two Queen
to d7 also Magnus Carlsen has done a
good job he's completed his development
if you look on white side of the board
he still has a lot of material to
develop on his side at night here to d2
rook to e8 getting it involved into the
center of the board
pawn c3 a bishop back here f8 opening up
the door for the rook to get involved
protecting the pawn here on e5 and the
knight - f - looks like the Knights
gonna be coming here to e3 really
controlled the center of the board if he
ever wanted to come to d5 or f5 he has
those options as well
Carlsen continues with pawn to h6
just blocking off this square on a g5
very important in this opening in the
knight to h2 and I thought this was very
odd I was not expecting Knights - H -
you know maybe since he has his knight
here decides to want to blow up the
center of the board pawn to d4 we
already talked about Knight - III that
makes a lot of sense
Knight to H - I'm not really sure where
he's expecting to go it doesn't make a
lot of sense to play Knight to g4 both
of his knights are just kind of hanging
out here pretty passive magnus carlsen
has a much more aggressive opening I
just can't imagine that cardiac and as
he looked at game to study that and came
back in game 4 and says okay I've got
some momentum here I want to try to play
an opening where I just kind of hide
both of my knights on the Kings side and
not be aggressive to let magnus carlsen
take the initiative on board just seems
very very odd to me not exactly sure
what his plan of attack is but Magnus
Carlsen says okay if you're gonna move
your knight away from f3 which was
defending the center of the board here
I'm gonna go ahead and start to attack
the center of the board so that's
exactly what he does paneer DD 5 now
Queens f3 pretty aggressive to get your
Queen involved protecting this pawn here
now what is interesting to note is this
also opens up the door it is attacking
the knight here you can see this pawn is
protecting the night but the bishop can
easily come over here to h6 at some
point and if the pawn recaptures and all
of a sudden the knight could fall so
something to keep in mind Knight to a5
attacking the bishop can't play that yet
he does need to defend his Bishop so
Bishop back here to a2 pawn takes on e4
pawn recaptures and then Knight to c4 so
this particular spot a Sergey Kuryakin
does have the green light and decides to
go ahead and play Bishop takes on h6 and
then Queen to c6 says hey I can go ahead
and take on the center of the board if
that's what we need to do definitely not
going to be taking and allowing you to
take that night here on f6 that's going
to be bad Bishop takes on c4 and
Kuryakin he could have easily just
brought his Bishop back here to see one
he didn't like the fact that his bishop
was kind of blocked off from everything
so decides to go ahead and get that off
the board but I actually really like
this pawn here on c4 from Magnus Carlsen
it's very aggressive controlling a lot
of the board it's just really deep in
his opponent's territory so really like
that for madness cross him Bishop back
here to e3 and as we said Magnus Carlsen
kind of get that material back as he
sees fit so Knight to e4 capture on that
up here to g3 then I comes back here to
d6 is I don't want to go ahead and
exchange those Knights on board I really
like my position Magnus Carlsen has
double bishop pair which is always nice
especially in this open board he also
has the only sinner pawn in the board
his opponent Kuryakin he doesn't have
any pawns past the third-ranked so if we
can't ever just analyzing this position
I would definitely say Madison has an
advantage which is pretty interesting
considering that Ryan Lopez is pretty
aggressive starting out with E for I
didn't expect Sergei Kuryakin to lose so
much in this particular opening so DK
continues with rook to d1 attacking the
stern of the board always nice Magnus
Carlsen rook to b8 says hey if we have
an exchange on board here once my bishop
leaves I can really start to put
pressure especially on the square here
on b2 it's not only on the second rank
but there's not much that I can do
except use a pea
to defend them that's exactly what he
ends up doing bishop back here to see
one not exactly where you want your dark
square and only Bishop left on the board
being just a defender of a pawn but
that's exactly what we see happen Magnus
constant pawn to f6 the Queen's exchange
on board I think this is good for Black
Knight here too G for the knight finally
gets involved not really sure why I was
ever on h2 in the first place
rook to b5 just gonna get it active can
always even bring his rook over here to
b8 kind of double rook here and then
maybe start to attack this dark square
Bishop and start to put pressure over
here on the Queen side pawn here to f3
pawns who have 5 forcing the knight to
move back here to f2 Bishop d7 wants to
get involved into the game pond up here
to f4 and then Bishop to h4 but this is
getting the bishop involvement of the
game I think I would immediately snap
high-five someone and play pawn to e4 I
think this puts a lot of pressure on
your opponent it kind of suffocates them
as far as where they can really move and
you you have a passed pawn now you can
now get your Bishop involvement of the
game Bishop here to h4 you have a rook
that's protecting that can start to push
that forward if you want to I just think
this is a really good square you have
the rook and the knight both protecting
this pawn here on f4 so you don't have
to worry too much about this Knight I
think it just puts a lot of pressure
Magnus Carlsen decided to go the
opposite direction Bishop here to h4
pawn takes on e5 and then Bishop takes
on g3 pawn takes on a d6 and then the
rook down here after they exchanged and
pawn to d6 Magnus Carlsen no longer has
to worry about the double pawns on the C
file and he still has the only central
pawn and he still has a really good pawn
here on f5 that he can start to push we
do see rook to d1 attacking that pond
and then King over here to f7 and then
rook up here to a d4 and it has to be
somewhat careful as far as just taking
material on board he can't always you
know obviously right now I can't take on
d6 because of the bishop so instead
decides to play a rook up here to d4
attacking this pond right here real
cover here to e5 fund says
you can't take my pond now because I can
just swing down here rook to e1 check
and I'm gonna take your bishop
so after this we see King here to f1 and
then a rook over here to d5 and he still
can't really take it cuz rook to c4 take
and then the Bishop to b5 pinning down
the rook to the king this is kind of in
a tough spot
pawn to b3 we do see in exchange maybe
on f2 then after this takes the bishop
takes and this is gonna be a pretty easy
in game for Magnus crossing with a rook
first a bishop he just gobble up all
these materials all these pawns he can
put all of his pawns on light squares
the bishop can't really do anything on
board so he decides instead of doing
that if we come back and says I'm just
gonna exchange material on board I also
think this is good for Magnus Carlsen
getting into the in game it isn't open
board say he does have a double bishop
pair I think this is gonna be in game
that he really likes if there's anything
I know though it's this is not going to
be a short game there's no clear path to
victory in the next 10 to 20 moves but I
can really see Magnus Carlsen just
grinding down his opponent similar to
game 3 I think it's gonna be very
difficult for security Acton to find a
win here but my guess is he kind of
senses the Magnus Carlsen is going to be
grinding down potentially a long game
and if he could just kind of hold on
from their madness Carlsen gonna be
trying to get that victory he be he
probably thought he should have gotten
in game 3 so da plays a Bishop to g5
King to g6 just getting the King
involved into the game now that the
major pieces are off the board the King
becomes a very valuable piece in the
game pawn up here to age for protecting
that King to h5 Knight here to h3 and
then a bishop up here to f7 I think this
is probably better than the bishop
taking on h4 I don't think he wants to
give up that Bishop pair so you just see
Knight to f4 check forcing the King to
move you could see the bishop take King
take and all of a sudden Bishop first
bishop I just don't think that's nearly
as good
so decides to go ahead and play Bishop
here it's
to f7 first and then we see the bishop
come to e7 and then the bishop takes on
h4 Bishop can't really recapture is that
you know hey I don't want you to have a
double Bishop here because these are
just gonna be down a pawn in material
since his opponent did take the pawn
here in age four he decides to go ahead
and take here on d6 and that's gonna be
completely fine by Magnus Carlsen Bishop
back here to d8 King here to e2 pawn
here to g5 so it starting to push the
little bell on the king's head he
recognized this most of his material is
on the Kings side he does have a pawn
advantage it's gonna be difficult for
his opponent to come over here to the
Queen side and push his pawn advantage
so he's gonna focus over here right now
Knight to f2 King to g6 pawn up here to
g4 and then Bishop to b6 this is another
one of those moves I think I would
immediately snap and just play pawn to
f4 but that's K decide to go and play
Bishop to b6 Bishop to e5 pawn here to
a5 night here to d1 and then we see pawn
to f4 now if you saw a lot of commentary
a lot of high-level grandmasters kind of
even pointed out this particular move
and said this kind of closing the game
may make the in game somewhat difficult
for Magnus Carlsen he definitely still
has an advantage on board double bishop
hair I think he just has better pawns in
general
he already has a passed pawn right now
so I think that's good but all in all
I'm not sure that that's not what Magnus
Carlsen once if you tell them hey this
is gonna be a really long game do you
have the stamina you gonna wear down
your pony be like yeah that's exactly
what I'm going for so a lot of people
would say yeah just take here on g4 and
then you know night to e3 Bishop here to
e6 protecting that and then Bishop back
here to g3 kind of stopping that the
pawn pushing forward I just don't think
that's what Magnus Carlsen wants to he
has double pawns here and I think it's
also important to note that the the
square that he would promote to here on
g1 which is the goal of pushing those
pawns is the same color that the start
square bishop is now if we compare that
to the pawn here on f4 is that's pushing
it's pushing to
light-square I think that's much better
I think Madison chose the right path to
victory that's kind of where he's going
for so Bishop here to d4 bishop up here
to a c7 night here to F to Bishop e6 and
so both sides are kind of doing this
song and dance of just maneuvering
pieces seeing where their opponents go
seeing if they can find any small
victories mat has crawled it at some
point since he has a pretty good
foundation over here on the kingside he
can start to move his king over to the
Queen side maybe see if he can get his
King behind enemy lines to chip away at
this pawn right here if he could even
get his bishops to block off some of the
squares keeping his opponent from coming
over here to the Queen side that would
be ideal as well
cardiac in plays King to f3 a bishop
here d5 check came back here bishop down
here g2 I think this is a really good
square it stops the knight from coming
here to h3 it stops it from coming here
to e4 puts a lot of pressure allows him
to still play pawn here to f3 I think
that would be a pretty good square as
well so all in all pretty good move I
think King to d2 that's a play king to
f7 and start his journey over to the
Queen side King here to see to Bishop
back here to a d5 says now that your
Kings here on c2 I don't want any
shenanigans with pawn to b3 even
something even crazy with pawns who b4
so I want to have protection here with
my bishop to d5 I think he's still
pretty got could have gotten away with
not doing that but it's had to play it
you know pretty pretty cool calm and
collective he does have the advantage
wants to make sure nothing crazy happens
here to d2 Bishop up here to d8 keen to
see tube then the King starts to get
involved you can see Magnus Carlsen does
a good job of just moving as King on the
light squares anytime your opponent has
just one Bishop kind of look at that hey
it's a dark square Bishop you can really
focus your pieces on the light squares
NAPA to your case takes a lot of the
thread away from that dark square Bishop
so King here to c6 King kind of dances
back and forth King here to be 5 and
then King here to see one says if you're
gonna move here to a4 I want to go ahead
and move up here to see two instead of
playing c2 and then once you move you
kind of force me away from that
King here 2 eights 4 and then King here
to see - and he's doing this because
black has tons of squares he can go - he
has lots of in between moves white
doesn't have as many in between moves he
can't move his Knight because then it
just gets kind of awkward I can't really
move his bishop too many good squares he
can't play any of his pawns anywhere and
if he moves his King too far away
then all of a sudden he's gonna lose his
pawn structure over here so certain game
kuryakin's kind of holding on for dear
life right now
bishop back here to f7 kind of the
in-between move King to c1 he could have
if he wanted to play bishop back here to
g7 as an in-between move and then Bishop
to e6 Bishop e5 Bishop to d7 it's not
clear how - Carlsen will continue I
think it's a very tough in game for
Magnus Carlsen in any position but came
back here c1 bishop g6 King to d2 and
then King to b3 so this is exactly where
he wants to be but it's it's still gonna
be tough to really break through does
need to protect that pawn here on b2 now
Bishop down here d3 a nice little
outpost move Knight to h3 attacking this
pawn is still being protected by the
bishop up here on d8 Knight - a - I
think you could have even just taken the
bishop here on d3 that's why I may not
have even brought my bishop down here to
d3 and mess with it but you know cardiac
and decided he's not gonna go ahead and
take that so as you go and play and then
over here to h3 king a to Bishop up here
c5 Bishop e2 Knight F - both sides just
posturing a little bit King here - C - a
[ __ ] back here c6 Bishop d7 Bishop d7
Bishop c5 Bishop c7 Bishop d4 right now
each move they make they get time back
in the game so they don't have tons of
time so they're just kind of moving
their pieces back and forth they
recognize that they don't have a clear
path for either of them right now so
they're just kind of moving their pieces
as they see fit
bishop here c5 f3 so we've we finally
have a line drawn on this end that
magnus carlsen says how i have the
position that I kind of like
go ahead and play f3 and start to push
that passed pawn that I've kind of had
in the game for a while
Bishop down here III Bishop d7 and then
King to c1 and this is definitely better
you don't want to be taking here on a g5
then it gets kind of crazy with Bishop
to b6 on the night up here to e4 and
then just pushing pawn to f2 can't
really stop this have to take it with
your knight here it's going to be taken
right here so does not want to do any of
that decides to instead play King here
to see one Bishop back here c8 King here
to see two same thing don't want to be
taking with your Bishop here on g5 at
night here to d7 King here to c1 and
then we see Bishop to f4 I think this is
very odd I would be getting the bishop
down here to g3 I'll be a little bit
more aggressive on board no idea why he
decided to play Bishop to f4 not sure if
he's just getting tired wanted to kind
of give up that advantage but decided to
go and play Bishop to f4 we do see an
exchange on board he does had double
pawns here but he just doesn't have the
raw material to really attack and push
past this one Bishop is not nearly going
to be enough so kind of gave up the
advantage to be had King here to see two
Bishop to e5 King here to see two Bishop
e6 c2 we kind of do this song and dance
we have a two-fold repetition Magnus
Carlsen says okay I don't want to have a
drop on three-fold repetition so I'm
gonna go and do something different King
here to b3 decides to go ahead and get
his King up back out of the Queen side
start to move it over to the King side
on board King here - e - d v f1 we kind
of move a little bit back and forth
Knight to f4 King here to g6 and then
King to f2 and after King to f2 you kind
of knew that the game was over this is a
critical square black really can't move
this King off this square he doesn't
have a minor piece that can really do
that and so for all intents and purposes
this is a drawl he's not gonna be able
to push these ponds past this so they do
a song and dance for a little bit longer
the bishop takes here on g4 okay that's
fine night here to d2 says I can take
this pawn here can it can also take this
pawn here on f3 you can take that's fine
you're not gonna be you know pushing any
further a [ __ ] peeler to e5 protecting
the pond and decides to go ahead and
take here on f3 that's fun
King to f5 pawn up here to a for Bishop
a d5 check great bringing the King back
here to f2 pretty safe King to g4 Knight
f1 King g5 night to d2 King f5 Keaney to
King to g4 and then all of a sudden the
King comes back here to f - a - caution
recognizes I just can't do anything on
board I can't stop the king if he's on
f2 so after 94 moves they decide to go
ahead and draw this game could have been
draw a long time ago I think a lot of
this is psychological for Magnus Carlsen
he thinks he probably could have found a
victory although I don't think it was
this clear in game 3 he just missed a
victory in Game three Game four although
he had an advantage for most of the game
I don't know that he could have actually
found a clear path to victory but at the
end of the day he did grind down his
opponent cardiac kids got to be sitting
there like I don't know what to do
against this guy every opening I throw
he comes out ahead
he gets me into the end game and then I
have to sit there for five more hours
trying to figure out the best move
because any kind of small mistake I make
I'm just going to end up losing that's
kind of a tough spot to be and when
you're just defending defending of
defending it's not really even it's fun
to play as chess you want to be the one
attacking like madness Carlsen so all in
all four games we have four draws at
least the last two have been more
productive but this one that has been
very long so for those that stuck with
me this entire video with all the prep
and recording I stuck with you glad you
stuck with me thank you guys we do have
a day off tomorrow and then we come back
- Carlson game 5
I'm hoping for something absolutely
crazy he comes out with fireworks in
game five just demolishes opponent in 20
moves just because I think it'd be
exciting so all in all thank you guys
for watching ninety-four moves and I'll
see you all in the next one see you guys